hey 42 here britain is brimming with
unusual customs and traditions
when we're not morris dancing
competitively eating
nestles or snorkeling free bugs
we can sometimes be found hanging out
around ancient stone circles
watching the sunrise or chasing giant
wheels of cheese down hills
but perhaps one of our most famous
traditions
is guy fawkes night also known
as bonfire night celebrated on the 5th
of november
bonfire night sees thousands of people
including large numbers of children
turning out to watch the ritual burning
of a criminal
the body of the condemned is usually
prepared by local kids
many of whom will stay with the man to
offer him comfort
in his final hours though they'll all be
cheering by the time the first flames
start to licket his feet
there's nothing like watching the body
of a traitor slowly begin to blister and
bubble
as the heat rises to get a crowd going
that's what i say oh hang on a minute
i've just remembered that many of my
viewers don't actually come from the uk
in that case i should probably point out
that we don't burn a real criminal on
bonfire night
that would be horrifying no we burn an
effigy of the celebration's namesake guy
fawkes
which now i come to think of it is also
a touch disturbing
but it's definitely better than
incinerating an actual human being in
front of thousands of smiling unlockers
and children
the reason for this probably quite
strange if you weren't born here
tradition
is rather simple in 1605
guy fawkes was caught red-handed trying
to blow up the houses of parliament
the seat of british government and if
you ever needed proof that we british
are masters of holding grudges this
should be more than enough to convince
you
every year we burn a man's likeness to
ashes
for daring to mess with our monarch
despite the fact the monarch in question
king james the first has been dead for a
smidge under 400 years
but who was this mustachioed man
why was he so hell-bent on blowing up
the king
and was he really the villain that
history has portrayed him to be
at the turn of the 17th century england
was a country
bitterly divided by religion on one side
with a protestant
and on the other the catholics the
century before had seen henry viii
instigate the english reformation after
the pope had denied a request to a null
henry's marriage
to the first of his six wives catherine
of aragon
not overly impressed with this decision
which made it rather difficult for henry
to start putting the moves on his new
crush on berlin
he set about breaking ties between the
church of england
and the vatican from that point on
british catholics were persecuted
to some degree or other until the
beginning of the 19th century
at its worst that persecution meant
imprisonment torture or even
execution but when king james the first
ascended to the throne of england in
there was a great sense of optimism
within the catholic community
due to his more lenient attitude towards
all things catholic after all his own
mother
mary queen of scots was a catholic and
nobody likes disappointing their mother
not even kings
at first this optimism seemed to be well
placed
with king james announcing he was happy
for catholics to go about their business
being all catholic just so long as they
behaved within the law
but the new king soon discovered his
leniency was giving rise to rumors
that maybe he wasn't such a devout
protestant after all
not wanting to fall out of favor the
king did a complete
u-turn on his promises and publicly
announced his utter detestation of
catholicism
before promptly making it illegal to
practice the religion
on english soil whilst this move did
indeed serve to make king james more
popular with the protestants
he had firmly positioned himself as
public enemy number one
in the eyes of the catholics the king
was not
a stupid man and he knew his actions had
placed an enormous target on his back
this was a time when being a king in the
british isles
was a dangerous job indeed some
15 of james's predecessors had been
either
assassinated executed murdered
or euthanized which frankly would be
enough
to make anyone a little bit paranoid and
that paranoia centered on one thing in
particular
getting blown up now that might sound
like a
fairly specific kind of death to be
afraid of
but it turns out king james had very
good reason to fear
gunpowder his own father had been
murdered in the aftermath of an
explosion
when two barrels of black powder had
been ignited underneath the building
he was staying in fortunately for king
james
he had a secret weapon in his quest to
not get exploded his chief spymaster
robert cecil and the network of spies at
his disposal
basically the mi5 of their day if anyone
was going to succeed in killing the king
it was going to take a plan of utmost
cunning and bravery
and that's where our old friend guy
fawkes comes in
well not quite you see despite guy
fawkes being
very much the face of the gunpowder plot
today
he actually had very little to do with
the planning and organizing of it
the brains behind the operation was a
gentleman called robert catesby
katesby was a prominent catholic
requisite who had a bitter history with
the english monarchy
under the rule of elizabeth his father
had been imprisoned
on account of his faith catesby himself
had also spent time behind bars
for his involvement in a rebellion
against the queen
when king james had taken to the throne
katesby had shown
little faith in the king's promises and
had already begun plotting
devastating ways to end the protestant
rule in
england forever but to realize his
ambition
kate b would need help and so he
assembled
a crack team of trusted associates
this group of catholic zealots consisted
of thomas percy
john wright thomas winter and guy
foxx unlike the others who were men of
considerable stature and well-known in
london
guy fawkes was a bit of an enigma
he was a hardened military man said to
be highly skilled in matters of war
he'd recently returned from overseas
where he'd been fighting for the spanish
in the 80 years war not for its entirety
i hasten to add his relative anonymity
was an attractive prospect for katesby
who needed someone who wouldn't raise
suspicions whilst doing the dirty work
for what would become known as the
gunpowder plot
the five conspirators met at the place
where all great plans are made
the local pub the duck and drake inn to
be precise
it was here that ksb first put forward
his idea
to blow up the houses of parliament
using as many barrels of gunpowder as
the conspirators could lay their hands
on
but the plot itself was a little more
complicated than just
lighting a fuse and running away as fast
as possible
catesby wanted the plan to be executed
during the state opening of parliament
a grand ceremony that officially marks
the beginning of the parliamentary year
incidentally the ceremony still takes
place to this day
and it opens with a foreign search of
the cellars beneath the houses of
parliament
for reasons that will soon become very
clear
most importantly it was a time in place
when
not only the king but also his lords and
dignitaries
would all be congregated inside the same
building
one fatal blow would be enough to bring
protestant england crashing to its knees
but kate spee's plan didn't stop there
during the ensuing chaos the plotters
would kidnap the king's nine-year-old
daughter elizabeth from her home
in comb abbey the kidnap princess will
be placed on the throne as a puppet
queen
she wouldn't have any real power which
would leave the catholic rebels free to
begin orchestrating
another major religious reform this time
in their favor despite the terrifying
consequences they face
should the plan go wrong thomas percy
john wright
thomas winter and guy fawkes all agreed
to join catesby in his attempt to
overthrow the king
but making plans to bring down the
monarchy whilst drinking a pint in your
local
was one thing actually putting those
plans into practice was going to be
another entirely
catesby was a well-connected man with
his finger in many pies
and although gunpowder supplies were
regulated by the government
there were plenty of people willing to
bend the law
for the right price but the plotters
knew
a single barrel wouldn't be enough for
what they had in mind
and so 36 powder kegs were procured
all told around 2500 kilograms of gum
powder
more than enough to realize their
destructive intentions
the next challenge was to get these
conspicuous barrels into position
beneath the palace of westminster a task
that would surely be
next to impossible actually
not so much after initially making plans
to dig a tunnel
beneath the building thomas percy saved
him all the hustle
by simply leasing a cellar directly
below the house of lords
the very room where the opening of
parliament was scheduled to take
place with the barrels in position
all the plotters had to do was sit tight
and
wait for the opening of parliament to
begin
the ceremony was originally scheduled to
take place in may
but due to an imminent threat of plague
it had to be postponed
until the 5th of november sounds
familiar
but it was an awfully long time for our
plotters to sit and stew
with the knowledge that their explosive
plans could be discovered at
any moment quite understandably
several of the conspirators whose ranks
had grown to include
13 people by now were getting a little
twitchy
on the off chance the seller was
searched by government officials
guy fawkes had hidden the barrels of
gunpowder beneath bundles of firewood
but it wasn't just a plot being
discovered that was a cause for concern
some of the plotters were beginning to
worry they would be damned by
god as a result of their actions after
all everyone knows
thou shalt not kill hundreds of innocent
people with gun powder
it's pretty much christianity 101
some of the conspirators even had
friends amongst the intended victims
but katesby was unswerving
as far as he was concerned if they
wanted to bring down the monarchy
and an entire religion with it their
powder kegs were going to have to break
a few eggs along the way
but eggs turned out to be the right word
because one of the plotters was about to
crack
on the evening of the 26th of october
william parker
fourth baron montego to give him his
full
rather modest title was settling down
for his supper
when one of his servants handed him a
letter that had
apparently just been delivered by a
shadowy figure
who had since disappeared into the night
the baron was one of the elite few who
was scheduled to attend the opening of
parliament
the following month and so from his
perspective the contents of the letter
were
particularly startling my lord
out of the love i bear to some of your
friends
i have a care of your preservation
therefore
i would advise you as you tender your
life
to devise some excuse to shift your
attendance at this parliament
the letter will go on to warn that
anyone who attended the ceremony would
receive a terrible blow parker didn't
hesitate
he wrote to westminster where he handed
the letter over to the spy master
robert cecil who in turn showed it to
the king
king james poured over the content of
the letter meticulously
the words terrible blow caught his
attention
to him this could mean only one thing
gunpowder it was the beginning of the
end for our conspirators
on the 4th of november the king ordered
that the buildings in and around
parliament be searched
and when his men searched the plot as
undercroft they found guy
fawkes standing beside the hidden
barrels of gunpowder
now you could have forgiven poor old guy
for falling to his knees and crying like
a baby at this point
but forks was made of sterner stuff he
remained composed and
calmly explained that the cellar
belonged to his master
thomas percy and he was merely a servant
going about his daily routine the search
party left
with forks feeling certain they'd bought
the lie
but in fact he'd made a fatal error
by name-dropping fellow conspirator
thomas percy
a known catholic with a rebellious past
he'd raised even more suspicion later
that night the search party returned to
question guy fawkes further
this time folks told them his name was
john
johnson not convinced by quite possibly
one of the laziest fake names ever given
they proceeded to search him and in his
pockets
they found lung matches commonly used to
ignite barrels of gunpowder
guy fawkes was immediately arrested and
with that his fate was sealed
after his arrest a more for a search of
the undercraft was conducted
and the barrels of gunpowder were
discovered the news quickly spread
throughout london
and soon reached the other plotters most
of whom promptly soiled themselves
but one man whose underwear remained
resolutely pristine
despite the dire circumstances was
katesby
he gathered what men he could and rode
out of london heading for warwick castle
there they raided the castle stores for
gunpowder and muskets
before desperately trying to raise
support from their fellow catholics
without much luck dejected the plotters
holed up in a safe house
there they decided that despite the
plot's failure
they weren't going to go out without a
fight
unfortunately the gunpowder they'd
stolen from warwick castle
had gotten damp during the raid
rendering it useless
that is unless they could somehow dry it
out
british weather being what it is laying
the gunpowder out to dry in the sun
wasn't an option and so in their
desperation
the men placed the powder in front of an
open fire
but yeah if there was a list of things
not to put in front of an open fire
gunpowder would
probably rank pretty high up all it took
was a single spark
and in seconds a huge fireball had
engulfed four of the men
including catesby leaving them with
terrible injuries
the men took the accident as an omen
that their plight
was doomed which had been pretty obvious
for quite some time
if you ask me and it turned out
they were exactly right the following
morning
200 of the king's men besieged the safe
house
and opened fire robert catesby was shot
and killed in his hand he was clutching
a picture of the virgin mary
of the four plotters who'd met that
fateful day in the duck and drake in
all but thomas winter was shot and
killed
he along with the other survivors were
taken back to the capital
to join guy fawkes in the town of london
where they would face an even more
terrifying fate
immediately after his arrest fawkes was
questioned but refused to incriminate
any of his fellow plotters
insisting he'd been working alone when
asked why he'd been discovered
hanging around with a load of gunpowder
he demonstrated an
admiral streak of badassery by replying
that he
intended to blow you scotch beggars back
to your native mountains
in reference to the king's scottish
heritage
his fearlessness earned him a degree of
respect from the king
but that respect engendered no mercy
guy fawkes was subjected to two days of
unimaginable torture
before he finally broke down and
confessed
the details of the plot in all
eight plotters were tried for high
treason and sentenced to be hanged drawn
and quartered
which was about as pleasant as it sounds
involving being drawn to the execution
by a horse
a brief but non-fatal hanging the
cutting off of the prisoner's genitals
and the removal of their intestines for
a small incision
in their stomach finally they were
decapitated
and quartered literally cut up into four
pieces
with each piece being sent to a
different part of the country
where it would be put on display as a
reminder to all that
it's probably not the best idea to mess
with the king
on the 31st of january 1606 guy fawkes
was taken from the tower of london
to face this barbaric fate at the old
palace yard
situated in westminster directly
opposite the very building
he'd hoped to blow up but in one last
act of defiance he was able to launch
himself from the hangman scaffold
breaking his own neck in the process and
sparing himself the agony of the planned
execution
thomas winter would not be so lucky
to this day the author of the infamous
montego letter
the one that unraveled the whole plot
remains unknown
some believe it was francis tresham a
late addition to the plot he was known
to have associates attending the opening
of parliament
some people have even speculated that
the baron montego himself
wrote the letter hoping to curry favor
with the king
intriguingly some modern historians
believe that robert cecil
knew of the plot long before the letter
was delivered
some even speculate he might have aided
the plot's development
allowing the oblivious plotters to
acquire the undercroft
and obtain the gunpowder with relative
ease
even if he'd known about catesby's
intentions
it would certainly have been in cecil's
best interest
to allow the plot to develop for as long
as possible
knowing that the longer it appeared to
remain a secret
the more catholic zealots would
incriminate themselves by getting
involved how much cecil knew of the plot
can never be known for sure
but it's clear that its failure greatly
benefited the king
and the protestant cause the gun powder
plot was used to vilify catholics up and
down the country and
new stricter laws were put in place
preventing catholics from
voting practicing law or serving as
officers in the army
or navy to deter any future attempts to
blow up parliament
it was important that the events of the
gunpowder plot were never forgotten
and so in 1606 the observance of the 5th
of november act was passed
this act called for an annual
thanksgiving
for the failure of the plot and it's the
reason
that once a year in england you might
find yourself standing in a muddy field
breaking your teeth on an overpriced
toffee apple
whilst an effigy of a man in a big silly
hat
is ceremoniously incinerated on a huge
fire
these days guy fawkes has become
something of a cult hero
a man who once stood up for what he
believed in and showed great bravery
in the face of a terrible fate even if
you knew nothing about the gunpowder
plot before this video
there's a good chance you've come across
guy's mugshot before
a mask depicting his likeness was used
heavily in the film
v for vendetta and it's since become a
powerful symbol
for those protesting against the
establishment most notably through the
hacktivist group anonymous
whether you see guy fawkes as a hero or
not
one notable english professor once
described him as
the last man to enter parliament with
honest intentions
or if you see him as a villain who
attempted to end the lives
of hundreds of people nobody can argue
that
he's achieved a level of fame that few
in history can match
though admittedly that has come at the
price of getting ritually burnt alive
tens of thousands of times every year
for four centuries
you win some you lose some thanks for
watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks